-Ils ont 12 000 et 6000 abonnés chacun
POURQUOI, POURQUOI, POURQUOI, PORQUE ?
Par où me...nani ?
Je m'excuse par avance pour la casquette parce que dessous, il se passe un truc un petit peu particulier..
Je vous en parle très bientôt dans mon vlog au Japon qui arrive rapidement,
mais là, ON VA PARLER D'UN TRUC
Hummm... N'est ce pas ?
Samedi, sur Twitter, on m'a parlé d'une émission télé
qui parle de moi, et de Squeezie
J'en ai parlé sur Instagram, peut être que vous avez déjà vu.
On va revenir ensemble là-dessus parce que
je pense que c'est important .
Remettons les choses dans leur contexte,
Télé Matin est une émission qui existe depuis moultes années
Sur France TV.
France 2 en l'occurence.
Et c'est une émission qui s'adresse aux gens qui se lèvent plutôt tôt
Et j'imagine les personnes plutôt agées.
Jusque là TOUUT va bien .
Aucun problème.
Dans cette émission, ils décident de parler de jeux vidéo.
Là
Déjà normalement, si vous êtes un peu expérimenté avec la télévision française,
Ca commence à sentir un peu aigre doux.
C'est parti, regardons l'extrait ensemble.
NON.
D'accord..donc l'émission de vendredi marche, et l'émission de samedi a tout simplement été supprimée...
HUM HUMM...
Moi je suis hacker du dimanche, on va la retrouver, ne vous inquiétez pas.
J'ai retrouvé la vidéo. France TV: 0 Cyprien:1
Alors
"Le jeu en ligne,"
Le jeu en ligne, ouais
"se répartit comme une véritable, aujourd'hui communauté"
des communautés
" A travers le monde,"
Pas de soucis
"Et c'est Internet, évidemment"
Vous voyez, Internet
Tout est bon "qui est à l'origine de ces changements. Alors il suffit de voir le phénomène des Youtubers "
Des Youtubers
"des youtubers aujourd'hui les plus riches ,les plus suivis au monde"
AAAAAAAHHHHHH!!!!!!
Voilà
"youtubers" Qu'est-ce qui est collé juste après: "Les plus riches"
C'est, c'est même pas "Qu'-est-ce qu'ils font ", "Qui sont ils ", etc...
C'est d'abord: "qui sont les plus riches"
On va regarder d'autres interviews après, et vous allez voir que, on est pas tous égaux, voilà , face aux médias
Poursuivons parce que ..
Ca va être excellent par la suite
"Ce sont des youtubers qui jouent, en direct à des jeux vidéo."
"Ils se filment, ils commentent leur partie, et ça, ça s'appelle le gaming, alors"
Voici ce qu'est le gaming, ce qu'ils vont dire après ça :
" Et alors les stars, les champions du genre en france " les stars en France "s'appellent Cyprien et Squeezie, c'est ce que vous voyez là"
Je découvre, grâce à Télé Matin que je suis une star du gaming.
Certes, j'ai eu une chaîne qui s'appellait Cyprien Gaming, mais malheureusement elle n'existe plus.
Absolument tout le monde sait que je suis une bille en jeu vidéo hein !
Moi je joue juste à Animal Crossing et à Final Fantasy c'est tout !
Là déjà c'est bon, hein ! Les erreurs s'enchaînent mais ne se ressemblent pas !
On arrive à quoi ? Ca c'est le summum, le point culminant de cette émission
"C'est ce que vous voyez là, ils ont 12 000 et 6000 abonnés chacun"
What ?!
OK,OK,OK, on , voilà , on reprend un petit peu ...
Ca ne me dérange pas qu'on se trompe pour des chiffres pour moi
En l'occurence, j'm'en fous, si les gens disent: "Ouais, je crois que lui il a 2 abonnés"
Ca m'est égal
A ton avis, qui dit que avec Squeezie on a 12 000 et 6000 abonnés, ce qui n'est pas dégueu déjà, hein ?
Franchement, il y a plein de gens qui rêveraient d'avoir autant d'abonnés
Mais juste ça montre le sérieux porté aux jeux vidéo et aux youtubers
Je ne suis pas un youtuber réellement gaming,
Squeezie l'est quand même plus que moi, il a une chaîne twitch et tout...
Mais d'où viennent ces chiffres ?? Je pense que c'est 12 millions pour ma chaîne, qu'ils ont enlevé les zéros à la fin
Et je pense que pour la chaîne de Squeezie, ils ont pris peut-être Bigorneaux et Coquillages
Mais en même temps, ils affichent, vous l'avez vu...
la chaîne Squeezie Gaming, qui est sa chaîne de live.
RIEN N'A DE SENS !!!
Je respecte énormément toutes les personnes qui travaillent là dessus.
C'est juste que ça témoigne quand même un petit BALECOULLISME ambiant dans les médias
C'est à dire: oui, bon des milliers, des millions, bah ça va, on va pas se tortiller du cul
Mais
UN PEU DE SERIEUX !!!
On ne mérite pas un peu de sérieux ??
Là dans ce qu'on vient de voir, on a un ultra combo
Les chiffres sont faux.
On affiche absolument n'importe quoi
Et par dessus tout, qui sont les plus riches, ne parlons que d'argent ...
Et pour moi, ce n'est pas très important de s'être trompé sur des chiffres, etc
C'est juste le sérieux qui est porté sur..
Voilà notre profession de youtuber car oui c'est un métier car on envie.
Je vais désormais vous parler d'une émission, qui a fait grand bruit
Qui a accueilli pas mal de youtubers
Donc ça c'est pas mal
Mais dans quel but:
ON SE LE DEMANDE
C'est l'émission Salut les Terriens présentée et produite par Thierry Ardisson
On va revenir 2 secondes sur ce qui est dit , donc durant cette interview, c'était en 2014, donc c'est plus tout jeune tout jeune, hein
"Vous avez commencé en 2007, au départ c'était 200, 300 vues maintenant c'est des millions, c'est des chiffres hallucinants"
"Toutes vidéos confondues"
"Vous cumulez 100 millions de vues sur Internet"
Là on va parler d'un petit truc...
En fait, tous ces gens de télé, dans la presse, les médias
Aiment bien nous présenter avec des chiffres..
Et, derrière, il y a la question de l'argent qui arrive, elle est là ...
Regardez il a 100 millions de vues !!!
La Question De l'Argent arrive !!!
Là monsieur Ardisson me présente et il me dit: "ça fait 100 millions de vues"
tout le monde applaudit etc et on voit sur ma gueule...
"Vous cumulez 100 millions de vues sur Internet "
Sourire poli. En fait ces chiffres sont faux.
On est pas aussi loin que la mascarade des 12000 abonnés..
D'ailleurs un jour j'espère arriver à 13000 abonnés  "road to 13000 abonnés" mais en fait en 2014
J'étais pas du tout à 100 millions de vues confondues, on va vérifier ça tout de suite..Nous avons enfin les chiffres
Je sais qu'à peu près jusqu'à avril 2014
Il n'y avait pas 100 millions de vues mais 500 millions
Dans ma tête je me dis: "il s'est pas trompé de chaîne..." et là je fais un peu appel à ma mémoire mais il
Me semble avoir dit quelque chose là dessus c'est pour ça que je tire cette tête de
"Mais c'est pas 100 millions de vues" ça fait un peu arrogant de venir corriger, mais il me semble que j'ai dit genre c'est pas exactement ça mais
C'est pas grave, regardez comment ça se passe dans l'émission "100 millions de vues sur internet"
Sourire bizarre: "les 3 millions de fans sur facebook"
CUT!
Je suis mort de rire
Comme le titre était déjà créé en bas 100 millions de vues
Tu auras 100 millions de vues Cyprien OK! Mais si tu as quelque chose à dire on le coupe au montage mon petit pote
BOOM!
Et c'est la télévision ici, on n'est pas là pour..
Rigoler à faire des petites vidéos sur votre talent dans ta chambre !"
ET
On a parlé des chiffres.
Vous savez ce qui arrive derrière...
"Après à chaque vue, il y a une toute petite pub qui surgit" Là j'explique la monétisation
Comment ça marche la monétisation parce qu'il va me parler d'argent "donc c'est quoi cinq dix mille euros par mois quand même non ?"
Eh bah voilà ! Ca fait combien 5,10... Tout le monde veut le savoir d'ailleurs on va parler essentiellement que de ça...
Qu'est ce que je réponds à ça ? "de quoi vivre après c'est... le plus important pour moi c'est surtout l'indépendance en fait "ouais" j'ai pas besoin d'avoir.."
"vous voulez pas de chaîne, quoi "
"Ouais voilà une chaîne  ou quelqu'un qui me dit faut faire ci, ça,  un autre angle... Je fais ce que je veux "ouais
"Tous les matins je me lève j'écris quelque chose ça me plaît, ça me plaît pas"
Ces propos sont tenus en 2014, mais ils sont toujours vrais aujourd'hui.
Effectivement je peux gagner de l'argent mais je peux surtout le réinvestir dans des projets, des courts métrages,
Des sketches et faire d'autres choses aussi à côté,
Ca m'ouvre des opportunités de faire de la bande dessinée, des jeux vidéo,  et plein d'autres choses...
Vous verrez il y a plein d'autres actus qui vont arriver cette année, l'année prochaine..
Vouloir ma fiche de paye, et surtout,
Ma fiche d'imposition,
Ca n'a pas de sens !
voilà parce que ce n'est pas terminé oh non c'est en
2015 donc c'est un an après thierry ardisson tout ça
le grand journal feu le grand jeu réclament une structure malheureusement cette grande émission sur canal + nous invite avec lucas dans le cas d'une
promotion bien évidemment je pense que c'était pour le squeezie gaming show ou cyprien game show quelque chose comme ça et il nous invite sur
un plateau télé est-ce que la malédiction
se reproduire? vous allez voir quelque chose qui témoigne
grandement de l'intérêt et du sérieux porté aux youtuber et à ce qu'on créé "bon t'as des question
à leur posé je te laisse leur poser la première question"
je suis stréssé
C'est ça ma vie
je vais sur un plateau télé on parle d'argent ou alors c'est une enfant de 6 ans qui me posent des questions mais est ce
que cette petite coco qui est très gentil enfin me posais une question d'argent mais sûrement pas
" tu gagnes beaucoup d'argent avec ton travail bizarre ?"
Soyons claire une bonne fois pour toutes. Si ce genre d'émission
invité à stand-uper, un réalisateur, un comédien ce que vous voulez quelqu'un de la télévision
pour la promo de ce qu'il veut on s'en fout personne ne lui posera la question de combien ils gagnent
personnes on va dire alors est ce que ça t'a plu de bosser sur ce film
alors c'est quoi ce nouveau projet d'émission on peut voir un extrait
alors je comprends que c'est tellement nouveau pour les gens que du coup il faut un
référentiel mais à un moment il faut être plus curieux que ça si on continue à faire des vidéos
tous les jours année après année et à faire des projets c'est que oui on envie. Vous sentez que je me suis un petit peu échauffés?
je suis désolé on va regarder un dernier truc voilà ça c'est comme ça au moins
c'est bouclé on revient en 2014 c'est sur tf1 l'émission sept à huit présenté par harry roselmack
les caméra m'ont suivi quelques temps même pas une journée je pense dès le lancement de l'émission déjà je regardais ça j'ai fait "what ?" (-> Quoi?)
Vous allez voir "et vous allez découvrir derrière l'humoriste un peu potache un vrai businessman du web"
J'ai l'impression que le lancement a été
écrit avant même de tourner le reportage parce qu'en fait je parle pas de business ou qu'oi que se soit vous allez voir des réunions d'écriture ce
genre de choses donc même si le reportage il dit autre chose vous allez voir un business man du web
"cyprien iov à 24 ans
si vous ne le connaissez pas "j'ai aucun style" c'est que vous avez ratées la tendance des ados
après  quelques secondes dans le métro parisien il est reconnu par tous les passagers de moins de 20 ans "(un passager) on peut prendre une photo ?" "alors oui (cyprien)"  "(le passager) j'adore ce que tu fais!"
C'est très gentil il adore ce que je fais pourquoi filmer le métro ça ne sert à rien mais en fait il voulait des images
de gens qui me reconnaissent ils se sont dit tiens on va aller dans le métro voilà il y a des grosses caméras et du coup il y a
des gens qui se disent putain mais c'est quoi ces grosses caméras
et il me dit quelque chose lui tiens je vais demander une photo et en fait du coup ils ont eu exactement ce qu'il voulait pour
illustrer leurs reportages
montrer que des gens me reconnaissent dans la rue
je trouve que c'est une mise en scène très marrante et moi j'ai l'impression d'être une big star hollywoodienne "dans un café du quartier latin
cyprien prépare son proche un sketch
il n'a jamais pris de cours de comédie ni de théâtre contrairement à son compère julien josselin"
oui julien! "lui aussi humoriste sur internet mais ne connaît pas le même succès"
oh ça tire à balle réelle Julien je suis désolé
"ils préparent ensemble une parodie des réunions marketing des multinationales "chez Ikéa?" génial on écrivait les réunions "ça fait k l p k s tu voit?" "j'ai perdu des lettres quoi" "plus de voyelles!"
ça ça c'est mon vrai quotidien c'est pas être un businessman du web comme ils prétendent en tout cas je pense pas c'est  des réunions d'écriture
essaie de trouver des idées, travailler de la préparation des tournages, du montage et de l'écriture
c'est génial de revoir ces images là parce que voilà on écrivait ce sketch qui pour moi est très culte dans ma vie parce que j'adorais bossé là dessus
"aujourd'hui (ouh) réaliser" grand style ! "des vidéos humoristiques
il en a fait son métier grâce à la monétisation de ses 54 vidéo ils gagneraient entre cinq et dix mille euros chaque mois je peux en vivre comme ça c'est sûr
l'indépendance pour moi c'est déjà exceptionnel je cherche pas à être riches en faisant ça je veux juste être indépendant et faire ce qui me plaît sur internet
impossible d'en savoir plus"
impossible d'en savoir plus pourtant nous aimerons vraiment à voir sa fiche de paye ainsi que sa fiche d'imposition
on n'y échappe pas j'ai toujours la même réponse
encore aujourd'hui si je dois répondre je dirais je suis content d'être
indépendant ne fait pas ce métier pour l'argent c'est débile faites ça parce que c'est une opportunité de créer de
proposer du contenu à des gens qui sont loin de vous  ça c'est formidable si tu t'enrichis tant mieux ça te permet d'investir
dans d'autres choses mais c'est ça c'est ça être youtuber pour moi! Voilà merci la télévision pour ces grands moments de rire mais
également un
peu d'énervement je comprends tous ceux qui bossent à la télé qui essaient de faire des reportages des petits sujets et on leur dit vas-y
mais moi une ligne sur les youtuber mais c'est quoi je sais pas vas-y gratte hop il a 6 milles  abonnés 12000 et ils sont à côté
de la plaque je comprend un petit peu le processus
moi je souhaite qu'il y ai  de plus en plus de gens qui prennent ça quand même au sérieux et il ya plein d'émissions qui sont
vraiment superbes j'avais vu quotidien qui parlait des youtuber c'était intéressant j'ai participé à l'émission le tube qui était c'était vraiment mortel ça parler du fond
il connaissait le sujet, le 19 45 de m6 aussi
qui voilà à parler des actions des youtubeur  sur l'écologie sur tout ça en soit vous pouvez vous demander combien on gagne
mais arrêter de poser la question systématiquement si pour les journalistes
la seule question qui veulent savoir à mon propos un autre propos c'est combien on gagne
ça n'en vaut pas la peine je pense qu'il ya plein d'autres choses beaucoup plus intéressante à creuser
soyons positifs peut-être qu'on aura des émissions intéressantes au sujet du youtubeur et du jeu vidéo et de tout ça moi je dis
bientôt 13000 abonnés
voilà n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo peut-être qu'on sera voilà 13 000 ou 14000 un jour je ne sais pas
"road to 13000 abonnés" je compte sur vous !